Come to Pixtar in a box,
a joint project of Pixar animation studio
and Cannes Academy.
I'm Fran and I'm working on the technical part.
And I'm Alex and I work
aesthetics and plot.
(Fran) Pixar in a box will introduce you
with some of the basic skills we use to create our films.
(Alex) There are examples of true film challenges,
which show how the artist's idea can start on
a wave of technical creativity.
and how the advancement of technology can inspire
artists to invent new ideas for the screen.
You will meet artists, scientists
animators, programmers, sculptors
and many different people.
The thing is, most of them use skills,
which you may already be learning at school.
But here, in the Box, you will see how
with these skills we create cool things.
Before you get into the lessons,
you better see how everything is tied to Pixtar,
the real Pixtar.
Come on, come see!
At Pikar we are constantly working
on many films at different stages.
But everything starts with an idea.
For example, "Toy toys" may have begun as follows:
When children leave the room, the toys come alive.
I have always known that my people are doing so.
Our films start in the storyline department,
where with the director and screenwriter
we figure out what will happen with the help of sketches.
(Fran) is like a comic book.
(Alex) That's right, and while we paint,
the team of designers begin
to design the world and the heroes.
While they are painting and painting,
our sketches go to the editorial,
where all our drawings
are grouped together.
We adjust their duration, add music, replicas and effects.
Only he knew what was going on ...
Aaaaaaa!
By moving the frames through every stage of production
we renew the scene again and again.
That's where science and mathematics go into action.
- Who knew what was happening ...
Aaaaaaa!
What next?
The Streamline - we're ready to start making the movie,
who will go to the cinema, and this is in a certain order.
It is time for our technical artist to invent
how do we make the movie on a computer.
I have been working here for nine years, and I still have no idea
how you turn our drawings into a ready-made movie.
To be honest, in every movie we are stumbling something.
Hi, Geylan!
Hello!
You have been here since the "Toys game".
What was the complexity of each movie?
In the "Toys game" - everything.
I will show you.
We developed "Toys' game"
the whole process from scratch.
In "Monsters OOD" - the fur and the clothes.
In "Cars" - reflective metal surfaces.
Every new movie has a new technical challenge.
In "Inside Out" we had a hero,
composed of shimmering particles and needed
many people to figure out how to achieve this.
(Alex) Wow, what's it done for?
Its shape will be composed of dots and light particles.
It was hard. This is the seventeenth option.
Heroes have to move,
so someone has to control the model.
Like a puppet, right?
Yes, but instead of strings,
our animators use a computer program,
to move the characters in the digital world.
The next step is the decor.
(Alex) So, for Car 2 you've built all of London?
We needed a large part of the city,
because Meyer and McCain are quickly passing through it.
We figured out how to build buildings
with enough variety to look real.
(Fran) And we're moving through this decor
with their virtual cameras.
And now - the animation.
I know what animators are doing.
They bring life to the heroes.
(Fran) He sees how he moves,
but her clothes and hair are missing.
They will be added by someone else
down the line.
And this one is me
and about twenty other technical artists.
Where do you get all these T-shirts?
We build everything we see,
including tissues and surfaces,
which make the world and the characters trustworthy.
Next stop - lighting.
The lighting department is however very dark.
So there are no lights when you start?
No. We have to add
each light source.
Only in this frame there are 230 lights.
(Fran) Last stop - processing.
The movie is a series of images, that is, footage.
There is 24 per second.
(Fran) Here we draw the frames.
Combine everything here -
art, mathematics and science.
Processing a single frame can take over 24 hours,
and this is for only one shot,
if we have no obstacles.
It is unbelievable to look at the finished footage.
And it's even cooler because I already know how they were made.
It was the excursion. The next step is
jump back into the Box and choose a lesson.
Did you like something?
This one for building combinatorics robots
I find it cool.
What about the scenery?
Or the one about the animation of The Incredibles.
Cruel! I always wanted to animate.